for an average kind of job to work how
many people does it prior to getting
right
first official trip after the summer
break and prince william was in belfast
talking to emergency service workers and
volunteers about mental health
and inevitably covid19 the pandemic has
been a significant moment for the
reputations of many public figures
including the duke of cambridge it was
only a couple of years ago that we kept
seeing those headlines and stories
suggesting that prince william was work
shy and maybe reluctant to step up for
those royal duties but some high-profile
tours
and more recently how him and kate have
responded to kovid
has brought a real unexpected boost to
his profile
the cambridges like the rest of the
royals have had to adapt to working
differently
one little duck number two expected to
play their part during a time of
national crisis
as older members of the family have been
shielded because of the virus
with harry and megan now doing their own
thing over in america
it has of course led to comparisons of
the two brothers
and their attitude to duty emily andrews
wrote one of the first
articles about william being a reluctant
royal
one source said to me he wants to live
the life of gentleman farmer it's a very
nice life
in norfolk he had his lovely country
house he was working as an air ambulance
pilot
he wasn't doing many royal duties but i
think the last couple of years and in
particular the last six months has
really seen william
step up to the plate as a couple they
have come across
as relaxed and some might say more
relatable
i'm paying tribute to the incredible
work that nhs staff across the country
have been doing
we've also seen a statesmanlike shift in
williams demeanor in recent years
partly put down to his former private
secretary simon case who recently left
to head up the civil service
but i understand we'll continue to
advise the duke
tessie ojo has worked closely with
william through the diana award and
believes we are now seeing what this
future king
has to offer he really shows his own
style and
his style is completely different from
his mother
or i mean from his father or his
grandmother
because our world has changed and people
want and people want to feel that they
matter
and that's the thing that he constantly
portrays that
your pain is my pain even if though i
can't exactly walk in your shoes
but i can bring i can bring the
spotlight to your pain to help alleviate
it
i'm told that getting better mental
health support and training for
emergency workers is going to be a key
focus of his work this year
do you find when you do come to say
something it's quite cathartic
another initiative from a man who's
always known that everything he does
matters not just now but as a future
monarch
rhiannon mills sky news